dear dr teddrus dear president haya
dear dr azlem turechi
dear professor uber shaheen
distinguished guests
the history of science is made of long
periods of slow progress
followed by great breakthroughs and
scientific revolutions
our fight against malaria is a case in
point
for decades science has worked hard to
eradicate malaria
and the european union has been a proud
partner in this work
we have supported tens of malaria
research projects
ranging from diagnostics to treatments
from prevention to vaccines
and in the last 20 years the number of
malaria victims was
cut by more than half and still
more than 400 000 people die of malaria
every year
two-thirds of them are children under
the age of five
but finally a breakthrough may be
at hand we are witnessing the start of a
revolution in medical science
the revolution of messenger rna
in these months the whole world has seen
the power
of the mrna technology pioneered by
biontech
and others and you
dear islam to retche and ur shaheen
you have cut the time needed to develop
a new vaccine
from 10 years to 10 months
and thanks to this billions of doses of
a covet 19 vaccine are being produced
for europe and the world and the mrna
technology
can be a game changer in the fight
against other diseases too
including malaria
a safe and effective malaria vaccine has
long been an elusive target
but this could change now and this is
where today's initiative comes into play
today we're joining forces towards a
breakthrough
in malaria vaccine development
the european commission and the european
investment bank
are throwing their weight behind the
global effort
to develop mrna vaccines against malaria
we will do so through our infectious
diseases finance
facility and we will work together with
biontech
and with some of the main global health
actors
eradicating malaria is a realistic goal
and now we know that it can be achieved
already in this
generation indeed the time is now
this initiative is part of a broader
engagement
by the european union for health in
africa
and in the developing world
africa today imports 99
of its vaccines and our african partners
want to end this dependency and we want
to support them achieve this goal
last may at the global health summit in
rome
we announced the team europe initiative
on manufacturing
vaccines in africa
this initiative is backed by 1 billion
euros from the european budget
and the european investment bank and
some european countries
have announced that they will also join
forces
our very first goal is to bring
new technologies to africa
we're working together with
pharmaceutical companies
that successfully manufacture in europe
if we join forces mrna vaccines can be
produced
inside the african continent
but to create sustainable structures we
need to look beyond
covet 19 vaccines the new plants in
africa
could be shifted to production of new
vaccines
against malaria or against tuberculosis
and of course this is a project that
takes years to be set up
but if we succeed we will not only be
better equipped for the next pandemic
we also invest into an african continent
finally free from malaria
and i'm proud that europe is part of
this endeavor
thank you all for being here and for
your essential contribution
to radicate malaria